welcome to my third video blog I'm back
baby
Celeste I was in downtown Los Angeles at
the opening a BART platform and I wanted
to use this fly as an opportunity to
compose some of my thoughts on modern
art now the opening last night had a lot
of great exhibits as well as a whole
hell of a lot of beautiful people
gallerina 'he's not another term for
male gallery de would it be a gallery no
anyway there were paintings
installations sculptures a lot of
interesting stuff so much stuff in fact
that the whole event overwhelmed me and
I think this speaks to the foundations
of what I feel about modern art for
example there's a lot of installations
making use of iPod when I look at a
piece of iPod art I really don't know
what it is I'm supposed to be thinking
and I think that's because the history
of iPod art is a short one right so the
traditions of the main screen art forms
painting literature music filmmaking
sculpture dance theater poetry and we
even say comics all have a rich history
from which they draw a kind of strength
since the relationship with what came
before in these forms is so story no pun
intended
they necessarily add to their complexity
in a way new forms camp for example it
in my own book I referenced a Hawthorne
who believed that the object of his work
was to increase the audience's appetite
for complexity that I am bringing with
me and attaching to my work not only his
ideas but the ideas he drew from so on
extending back to the origins of
literature but this relationship goes
the other way to TS Eliot said what
happens when a work of art is created is
something that happens simultaneously to
all the works which preceded it the
existing monuments form an ideal order
among themselves which is modified by
the introduction of the new the really
new work of art among them the existing
order is complete before the new work
arrives and when it does arrive the
whole existing order must be ever so
slightly altered so really you can think
of the history of literature or painting
or dance or sculpture as a kind of
creature a living thing as complex as
the history of its form but necessarily
must change when a new thing is added to
it the point is that we're talking about
a level of complexity that iPod art just
can't stand up to yet no I believe like
Hawthorne did and maybe you don't that
the key purpose of any work of art if
there is any at all is to increase the
appreciation of complexity in the world
so getting it to our platform from last
night when I see these new forms of
installation art I feel a little bit
puzzled because I don't have that living
creature to compare it to there maybe in
100 years iPod arts going to have a
history like you never thought and then
you'll be able to look at the origins of
iPod art and say wow look at the
evolution
at this artboard Oh what the hell is the
2,180 ipod gonna look like the point is
I think and I'm maybe a little bit naive
for saying this but I need tradition to
appreciate some of this modern art of
course that's what they said about
filmmaking and now we're about a hundred
years on and look at what the copper
shofar is heart and soul
no surgeon way
Oh
is peace of mind you know
- fine but where
or where
you
right
stay strong with forbearers of iPod art
keep at it keep working I will see you
they were hungry years
you